♪ ♪
>> Jesse: HOLLYWOOD LASHING
OUT AGAINST CONSERVATIVES,
LIBERALS LINING UP TO DEMAND A
BOYCOTT ON FILMING IN GEORGIA
OVER THE HEART BEAT ABORTION
LAW.
THEIR PLANS ALREADY STARTING TO
FIZZLE OUT.
ACTORS AND SOME SMALL PRODUCTION
COMPANY SAID THAT THEY WILL NOT
WORK IN THE STATE, BUT BIG
STUDIOS AREN'T BUDGING.
AND ALYSSA MILANO IS BEING
MOCKED FOR TAKING THINGS A
LITTLE STEP FURTHER.
THE ACTRESS ACTUALLY CALLED FOR
A SEX STRIKE TO PROTEST THE LAW.
WOMEN DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
POWER THAT THEY HAVE WITH THE
SEX STRIKE THING.
I THINK THAT WE COULD DO THE
CHINA TRADE DEAL NEXT WEEK.
>> Greg: THIS IS A VERY OLD
IDEA.
IT IS BASED ON A PLAY.
AND I THINK THAT I'VE SEEN IT IN
A MOVIE WHERE THEY TRY TO GET
PEOPLE TO QUIT SMOKING BY NOT
HAVING SEX.
THIS IS MISOGYNY ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE ALYSSA MILANO IS
DEMANDING WOMEN TO FORFEIT THEIR
OWN CHOICE TO ENGAGE IN A
PLEASURABLE BEHAVIOR.
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION, AND GET
THIS, UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT
SEX IS A REWARD FOR MEN, NOT FUN
OR REWARDING FOR WOMEN.
SO IT IS AN OLD-FASHIONED POINT
OF VIEW.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
MEN SHOULD THROW A SEX STRIKE.
>> Greg: I DO THAT WHEN I GO
BOWLING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: COUNT ME OUT.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS GOING DOWN IN
GEORGIA?
>> Dana: I THINK THAT THE
DEVIL WENT DOWN IN GEORGIA.
AND HER NAME IS ALYSSA MILANO.
HERE'S THE THING THAT I WOULD
SAY TO STATES, YOU DON'T NEED
THESE GUYS, YOU DON'T NEED TO
BEND OVER BACKWARDS TO INVITE
THE MOVIE INDUSTRY INTO YOUR
STATE.
THE BEST WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
MOVE TO YOUR STATE IS TO CUT
TAXES, STREAM LINE REGULATIONS,
HAVE GOOD LAW AND ORDER AND GOOD
SCHOOLS.
THAT'S IT.
AND THEN YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
THESE SHENANIGANS AND THESE
PEOPLE THREATENING YOU, BECAUSE
YOUR STATE LEGISLATURE PASSES A
BILL THAT WAS REPRESENTATIVE OF
WHAT THE CONSTITUENCY SAID.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS
IN THE STATE SAID I HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT BENEFIT FROM
THE FILM INDUSTRY IN GEORGIA AND
INSTEAD OF BOYCOTTING, LET'S
JUST TAKE BACK THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE NEXT ELECTION.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
HERE AS I HAVE SAID BEFORE IS AN
EFFORT BY PEOPLE IN THE PRO-LIFE
MOVEMENT TO CIRCUMVENT
ROE V. WADE WITH THESE HEARTBEAT
LAWS THAT ARE NOW IN SO MANY
STATELY JUTE MEDICAL LASER
SLEIGH SHIRTS.
BUT POINT IS THAT BOYCOTTS ARE A
AMERICAN TRADITION.
THEY WERE SAYING THE NFL
PLAYERS, LET'S NOT WATCH THEM
FOR A WHILE.
THEY CAN WATCH WHAT THEY WANT.
OR NOT WATCH.
AND IF PEOPLE WANT TO SAY THAT
THEY DO NOT LIKE THE FACT THAT
THE WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS
BEING SO POLITICIZED IN THE
SOUTHERN STATES WERE THE MOST
PART, THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO ALSO
SAY THIS IS WRONG.
SO LET THEM GO.
>> Lisa: THERE A LOT OF
PRO-LIFERS PLOTTING ALYSSA
MILANO, BECAUSE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING CHILDREN
AND GETTING PREGNANT, BUT I WILL
SAY THAT ONE THING THAT IS
INTERESTING ABOUT THE HEARTBEAT
LAW IS IT IS FULL LEGAL RIGHTS
TO UNBORN CHILDREN.
THERE IS A LEGAL SIGNIFICANCE TO
THAT.
BUT ALSO A CONVERSATIONAL
SIGNIFICANCE IN THE WAY THAT WE
TALK ABOUT AN UNBORN CHILD,
BECAUSE THE LEFT GOES TO GREAT
LENGTHS TO DEHUMANIZE THE UNBORN
CHILD IN A WOMAN'S STOMACH.
THEY SAID THAT IT IS A LUMP OF
CELLS.
THEY SAY THAT -- A CNN COMMENTER
SAID THAT IT IS NOT A HUMAN.
IT IS EASIER TO ABORT SOMETHING
IF YOU DEHUMANIZE IT AND TAKE
AWAY THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
UNIQUE LIFE LIVING IN A WOMAN'S
WOMB.
THERE IS A SHIFTING IN THE WAY
THAT WE CONVERSE ABOUT ABORTION,